i mean pop jpeg you are not doing good
in terms of the presentation as a leader
everything from the outside look at it
is just not looking good
what's up reject nation disney ceo bob
chapeck is at it again with keeping his
marvel actors
happy
this guy
really knows what he's doing man he's
really made a name for you you don't
know a lot of ceos names but you know
this guy's name yeah this guy is
developing quite the reputation for
himself in terms of how to work with
your stars anywho guys see me lou has
some uh course words here in response to
something bob chapeck recently said
we're going to go through this go
through bob chapex said go through what
seemed loose said give our opinions on
it all weigh it all out but first
living here sucks i'm gonna tell you
guys if you guys haven't been following
the chronicles of greg's home i've
shaved and i was gonna shower because we
got the shanghi event to go to tonight
gotta pick up warm from the airport
about the shower and then the water is
turned off again and i went off on my
landlord if you want to see what i said
to him go follow me on twitter that's
what my twitter's forward a [ __ ] about
certain things the writer is for so
twitter's for okay so here is what
happened with uh what bob chapex said in
regards to the fact that shanghai is
gonna have this 45-day theatrical window
it's going to be the first movie where
it's not going to be available on disney
plus after 45 days there's not going to
be any dual release only theatrical
experience he said we actually think it
will be an interesting experiment for us
the prospect of being able to take a
marvel title to the service after going
theatrical for 45 days will be yet
another data point to inform our actions
going forward on our titles this
statement obviously came out way before
uh cmelu responded to it but when i
first heard that i thought okay yeah
that makes sense everything's kind of up
in the air everything's a big experiment
right now so i didn't read into it in
the way simi lou took this to heart so
see me lou responded this saying we are
not an experiment we are the underdog
the underestimated we are the ceiling
breakers we are the celebration of
culture and joy that will persevere
after an embattled year we are the
surprise i'm fired the [ __ ] up to make
history
on september 3rd greg's birthday join us
to say happy birthday to greg now i'm
very excited for shang qi in more ways
than one i've said in many times in many
videos someone who is asian myself seen
asian representation first asian marvel
lead i'm very very much enthralled just
by that fact alone and i have a lot of
faith it's gonna be a good movie do i
think that bob chapeck meant
it in the way how it can be received
i don't think so
i don't actually think that at the same
time the flip side here is
i can totally see how the other side of
the conversation could receive it this
way yeah and i think when you are being
a ceo and you are dealing with a movie
that has a a cultural movement around it
i do think you got to be more careful
with your choice of words do i think he
meant this in a racist way no i don't i
think he was just referring to the fact
of it's a marvel movie release strategy
again trying to release strategies the
first one that might have something to
do with the fact that early projections
are only estimating the box office to be
around 35 to 55 million dollars which is
pretty low for a marvel movie but you
got to keep in mind this character has
not been set up in a previous marvel
film other than like little easter eggs
that hardcore fans may have picked up on
right but it's not the same way as like
introducing captain marvel where
infinity war has you know post-credits
scene that's saying you have to watch
captain marvel before you watch end game
chongqi doesn't have that benefit to it
it's a brand new character and we are
living in a weird time right now no one
really knows how anything's gonna go and
no one does you can predict that
something might underperform or
overperform or do just fine but there's
a lot to be surprised by
in all of this so i kind of feel like
both here because when simile is saying
that i actually did not take the word
see me loose at it when he's talking
about saying we're not an experiment
we're the underdog they underestimated i
feel that as someone who is asian myself
i do feel that this is a big deal this
is something to overcome here this is
something to create some cultural waves
here this is really exciting and to be
told on the receiving end that you're an
expert like i can see totally see how it
feels like you're being told and the
people involved are as people you're an
experiment for this it can sort of read
as we don't really know how it's gonna
do we don't really care too much about
it so we're just gonna experiment with
this and throw it to the wind yeah you
know yeah yeah it's strange because even
though i don't think bob chapeck meant
it in that regard i still would decide
more with how simi lou took it because
that is just a poor choice of words
there on bob japex end yeah i mean i
feel like bob chapek has the unfortunate
and this is just a projection of my own
but i feel like he's so into the money
and the numbers that he's not really
speaking as somebody who is looking at
the full scope of what the movie is and
what it's trying to do and where it
lands in the mcu and all that other
stuff and so yeah i can see easily how
this conflict has arisen because it's
easy to to feel like yeah this is an
experiment also with multiculturalism
and there's already so much that rides
on the success of movies like this when
it comes to the box office and in a time
where there are so many natural
variables that are affecting all this it
seems like the application of the
recognition of those variables isn't
always on the level and so basically
this movie's in a tough position because
if it doesn't perform there are so many
reasonable reasons for that and yet it
might damage the chances of seeing
another asian-led or predominantly asian
cast movie being made on this scale and
being delivered to us on this scale so
while i am sitting here going i feel
like he just meant we're gonna you know
experiment with not doing dual release
for a minute but then a really quick
roll out to disney plus after the
theatrical part and see how that works
you know i get it from a business
standpoint sure try something else it
seems almost better than doing a dual
release at the moment but yeah it also
kind of speaks in a way that sounds like
uh yeah we're we're trying stuff out on
this movie whereas you know you maybe
wouldn't want to make this the
experiment movie given that it already
has so much ground within just culture
to make up to bring people in for
because what i want to add to why i'm
saying i get where see me lou is coming
from is that as disney ceo you are the
leader and as the leader you should be
encouraging people and you should be
hyping it up you should getting people
excited and people who probably weren't
as excited should be going you know what
yeah i'm going to go check out chongqi
instead of kind of just having this sort
of flipping attitude
it's sort of like just throw it to the
wind and let's it kind of reads that way
as like let's just see what happens
instead of let's get people into
theaters this is a big deal this is our
new marvel hero i too you know invested
in the success of this yes and he
doesn't read that way i do feel like bob
iger might have done that if i'm gonna
be totally honest
i gotta miss
these days well he's just so much more
poised in this position it seems like
and like see me lou this is his first
movie with marvel this is his first one
and it's really strange it's so
fascinating to me how like scarlett
johansson a legacy character within the
mcu suing disney having issues with bob
chapeck this guy doesn't even have his
movie out yet no he's already going up
against you so i'm like how is everyone
feeling about this guy how does everyone
feel about bob chapeck because for him
to certainly speak out against him and
his words like he's doing more promotion
for the film he's certain like to me
when i read this i'm like yes let's go
let's get this movie out there yeah i'm
excited yeah it's not just treated like
an experiment let's encourage people to
go out there and watch this movie where
bob chaffeck's like let's experiment
we'll see how it goes some stuff out you
know the next movie we got people don't
really know chiang chi let's let's let's
experiment yes
in terms of the presentation as a leader
everything from the outside looking is
just not looking good
yeah i don't know i mean not no shade to
theme park folks but it doesn't seem
like he's absolutely suited to the film
business
yes ah man caught this article last
night and then i was like damn this is
surprising
and it is it is weird to me how like i
didn't actually
think of it and that like all these
thoughts were coming to me after i read
seem to lose tweet then i realized like
oh yeah bob chap doesn't really seem to
be trying to get people excited about
this yeah whereas he's like just a lot
of trailers or whatever do it but see me
lou he's working on ramping people up
and encouraging people to go out there
and show that we can still dominate even
in these times yeah and i feel like
there's a it seems to me like there
would have been an easy way for bob
chapic to get pretty much the same
message out because it's not unfair to
experiment in uncertain times but while
also showing some big support for the
movie and maybe hopes that that
experiment will be a roaring success or
something
something that yeah makes your talent
feel like you got their back and that
you're invested in them too true
all right guys what do you think about
this situation how are you feeling about
how bob chapeck is doing with these
things maybe he'll be at the premiere
that'd be fun
we'll talk to him we'll just send us
comments for him you know john campbell
did a video on this earlier and he's
gonna be at the premiere i haven't seen
his video yet
but uh i'm assuming that some there's
certain subjects where i know camping i
will kind of be on the same page about
some things and i i imagine we're on the
same page about this one you know oh i
got it actually
yes
he
he responded to his tweet i gotta check
how can't you this video could be a rant
on this uh
i know can't be it could be a bit of a
divisive personality within our
subscriber base but uh videos like this
are oh yeah okay go watch it on campus
video i haven't seen it yet but i'm
assuming it's a lot more heated than how
we presented ourselves
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click the notification
bell hit that like button are you gonna
watch shanghai in the theaters and wait
for that 45 day window to open up
see you guys
[Music]